So it looks like no matter how much you exercise,
you’re sort of screwed anyways.
Hey guys, Amy standing here for DNews because
there’s more research out that shows sitting
is bad for you!
We’ve heard this before: sitting is bad.
We’re supposed to be all up and at ‘em
all day.
But most jobs don’t allow that; a lot of
us are sedentary at work, then unwind in front
of the TV in the evening.
But you work out three days a week or walk
home?
That’s good, but it’s not quite enough.
Exercise isn’t the problem, it’s the amount
of time spent sitting.
At least, that’s according to a new study
published in the Annals of Internal Medicine
from a team of scientists based at the Toronto
Rehabilitation Institute.
The team studied sedentary behaviour and found
that the health hazards associated with sitting
seem to be greatest for people who sit 8 or
9 hours a day.
The impact was even more pronounced in people
who did not exercise regularly.
Sitting for prolonged periods has a lot of
risks, including a 14 percent increased risk
of cardiovascular disease, a 13 percent risk
of cancer, and an insane 91 percent increase
in diabetes.
And sitting for a long time with no breaks
for stretching or exercise comes with a 40
percent higher risk of early death.
The longer you sit the higher the risk, and
the risks aren’t entirely offset by exercise.
Sitting for prolonged periods increase your
insulin resistance, meaning your body can’t
process the sugar in your blood and move it
into your cells as efficiently.
Sitting also burns an extremely small number
of calories, leading to problems associated
with obesity.
And if you’re not sitting with your feet
and lower back supported you can develop hip
and lower back problems, problems that you’ll
have a hard time recovering from if you’re
already not active.
The study authors suggest getting up and stretching
or moving around for just a couple of minutes
every half hour or so.
So what can you do to be a little active and
burn some calories exercising just five minutes
an hour?
You can burn about 20 calories walking at
a moderate pace.
If you’re at home, brush your teeth to burn
12 calories and up your dental hygiene game.
If you don’t mind people staring at you,
burn about 40 calories in five minutes doing
pushups or walking up and down the stairs.
Jumping rope, or just jumping, burns 50 calories
in 5 minutes.
The US Department of Health and Human Services
suggests instead of sitting, you can pace
around your office during conference calls.
Other tips include using your lunch break
to fit in some physical activity, or getting
up to go talk to a co-worker instead of emailing
them.
At home, scrubbing your floors to burn about
60 calories in five minutes!
If you scrub during every commercial break
with your evening TV, you’ll be a little
healthier and have clean floors!
Or consider doing push-ups or sit-ups WHILE
you watch your favorite shows.
So what do you guys do to stay active?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
catch me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.